zorlukları uygun biçimde kullanırsanız
zorluklar aracıyla büyüyebilirsiniz
ebruhan twooski ıstakoz
Oğlum doğru duydunuz Ben bir ıstakozum
bu çocuk pelte gibi hayvanlardır
kabukları serttir büyüdükçe rahatsızlık
hissederler kabukları dar gelir bu
kabuğu kırmak için güvenli bir kayanın
altına geçerler ve Avcılardan korunurlar
bu süreç döngü halinde devam eder evet
bu hikaye hep beni etkilemiştir Adrian
bu hikayesi Hayat felsefeme oldu Ben de
hep zorluklarla mücadele sonundaki
güzelliklere kavuşmanın hevesiyle
yaşayan biriyim
Benim Hikayem gözleri çok iyi gören bir
çocuktum atlayan zıplayan yerinde
duramayan merdiven kullanmayıp
trabzanlardan kayan ve 10 yaşlarında bir
hafta içerisinde Çok ani bir görme kaybı
yaşadım ama
vizyonlar bir aileye sahip olduğum için
bu fırsatı çok iyi değerlendirdim her
hafta okul gibi tiyatroya gittik Annem
ilk önce bana Polyanna okutturdu
sonrasında yavaş yavaş adapte olmaya
başladım kitabı yakından okuduğum için
ezberledim okulda arkadaşlarımın yanında
mahçup olmamak için Hatta bazen
öğretmenim yüzüne bakarak okurmuşum
Bunun sayesinde hafızam çok kuvvetli
oldu ve Avukat olmakta zorluk çekmedim
tabii kolay değildi her zaman başarı
elde edemiyorsunuz atıyorum masal
yarışmasını katılırdım
ve hikayemi kendi kendine oluşturur onu
aktarırdım
ve
2014 yılı hayatımın dönüm noktası mucize
gibi hayatımda ilk defa benim gibi
merkezden görmeyip yandan gören
olaya başlamış Ve benim gibi mücadele
sevgili Dostumla tanıştım Kendisi çok
kıymetli Ankara Büyükelçisi Richard More
verdik iki farklı milletten iki kadın
Evet biz topluma hizmet etmek için
Türkiye'de bir ilki gerçekleştirdik ve
Türkiye'deki ilk sığınuşu rehber
köpekler Derneğini kurduk rehber
köpekler Derneği kurulduğunda
hiçbir şeyimiz yoktu Herkes bize
yapamazsınız dedi biz yaparız dedik bir
redar köpek iki yılda yetişiyor ve bu
rehber köpeklerin yetişmesi için gönüllü
aileler yaklaşık bir yıl kapılarını
yavru köpeklerimize ölçüyor rehber
köpekler Derneği bunun veterinerin
mamasını eğitimini her şeyini temin
ediyor sonrasında sınava giren
dostlarımız Eğer bu sınavı geçerse
rehber köpek oluyor daha bitmiyor 3 ay 6
ay arasında köpeğin kapasitesine göre
eğitim gören rehber köpek adaylarımız
sonrasında görme engellilerle
eşleştiriliyor ama görme engelli
eğitimde Öyle kolay değil
3-6 hafta arasında önce rehber köpekle
yaşamayı öğreniyorsunuz bize kara ile
öyle öğrendik sonrasında sokaklara
çıkıyorsunuz ve rehber köpekler daha iyi
tamamen bunu bedelsiz yapıyor Biz
toplumumuza aldığımızı topluma hizmet
olarak sunmaktan mutluyuz ilk günlerde
böyle sokağa çıktık işte metrobüse
bindik
hiç unutamam şimdi sahnedeyiz Biz
aslında kralıyla profesyonel izleyeceğiz
ama ilk devlet tiyatrolarında kabul
edilmeden önce prova'ya katıldık Karanın
kulağında davul çaldılar Kara böyle
deyip arkasından Yaşasın uyuyabilirim
moduna girdi ardından
beraberce birçok konferansta konuşmaya
katıldık hiç tükenmeden herkese belki
günde 10 defa rehber köpeğinin ne
olduğunu benim göremediğimi yardım
ettiğini anlattım bugün geldiğimiz nokta
bizi çok mutlu ediyor ve motivasyonumuzu
arttırıyor bu konuda farkındalığı
yarattık göremeyen kişiler sokağa rehber
köpekleriyle çıktığı zaman rahat ve
bağımsız hareket edebilirler algısına
oturttuk Ama tabii ki daha yapılacak çok
şey var ve Evet videomuz
[Müzik]
Biz gönülleri olan ve kocaman bir Yüreği
olan
gönüllüleriz rehber köpekler Derneği
bundan sonra daha da sürdürebilir
çalışmalarına devam edecek Ben bireysel
olarak da göremeyen arkadaşların
özellikle stajyer avukatların işe
yerleşmesinde yabancı dil öğreniminde
gönüllü olarak destek veriyorum çünkü
hala hala algı çok düşük göremeyen
kişiyle müvekilinin tanıştırmak
istemeyen avukatlar veya işte imza
atarken sana bir Tanık gerek yok
diyenler oluyor Bunu hep birlikte
değiştireceğiz
benim vazgeçemediğim tutkularım
çocukluğumdan beri hep kendime meşgul
ettim hep bildim bileli eğitimin kursu
mu oldu Evet koştum senden bisiklete
başladım ikili Bisiklete binmek muhteşem
Çünkü az gören bir çocuk olarak
biniyordum ama sonrasında binememiştim o
kadar büyük keyif verdi ki hele Flamenko
ayak ve el koordinasyonuyla ritimleri
dinliyorsunuz ilk 8'de yürüyorsun 2008
eteğini kapatıyorsun ve
sahnedesin Ama tabii ki şaşırdığın
noktalar oluyor ama sahne asla Durmaz
deyip aynı hayatta olduğu gibi devam
ediyorsun Ve tabii ki paraşüt en büyük
hayallerimden biriydi Bulutlara değmek
hissetmek bana yardımcı olan pilot
arkadaşla birlikte çok iyi betimlemişti
yamaç paraşütü yaptım Kısmet olursa bir
de ben bir de Camping yapmak istiyorum
ama bakalım O da bir daha ki sefere
spor ve dans vazgeçemeyen Vazgeçilmeyen
tutkularım
[Müzik]
bugün boğa festivalde Bizim de
slogger
gibi
[Müzik]
şanslıyım ama şansımı hak edecek kadar
çok çalıştım Asla pes etmedim ve
durmadım Nerede hareket orada bereket
dedim Tabii ki ben değilsem kim şimdi
değilse ne zaman taşın altına Elimizi
koymamız gerekiyor çünkü yapabileceğimiz
çok şeyler var kabuğumuzu kırmamız lazım
şimdi sizde Kendi kendinize sorun ne
zaman kabuğunuzu kırın kendinize bir
alan açın bu dünya hepimizin iyilik
yaparak iyi hissederek bizden sonraki
nesillere çok daha iyi bir dünya
bırakabiliriz teşekkürler
[Alkış]